[Music]
my name is Terry Ryan I'm a developer
advocate with Google if you have any
questions or comments probably the
easiest way to get them to me is my
twitter handle which I forgot to put up
here which is just TP Ryan and you can
handle me or ask questions or whatever
gonna do there so let me get right into
it the first question I like to kind of
put out to all you folks is who are you
helps me know like what level I need to
talk at and what jokes I could make that
sort of thing so who here does full time
systems work okay
who here does full times development
work who here does both because you love
DevOps or your boss hates you and won't
hire more people I saw hands go up yeah
uh wait how many people here tell
developers or systems people what to do
how many here are bosses ok good I
should have really asked I asked that
before I made a manager joke but I think
we outnumber you so we're good all right
so I have two goals for this talk today
first is to introduce and showcase the
abilities of our virtual machine
platform Google start compute engine and
then I also want to show off some of the
complementary technologies one of the
other things I will do is I'm a
developer advocate I'm not a sales guy
but I will talk a little bit about
pricing just because from my perspective
a lot of the a lot of the challenges
that happen with VM projects is are not
technical they are in fact usually
pricing related people go to the cloud
and get surprised from a pricing
perspective and that sometimes damages
those projects so I will talk about that
a little bit but let's get right into it
let's get into the basics and talk about
compute engine so compute engine is our
VM platform you can get anywhere from
0.5 to 96 processors although we do have
larger processor machines in beta
one-sixty I believe and then anywhere
from point six to six hundred twenty
four gigs of RAM and then in beta we
have much larger machines available you
can attach up to 64 terabytes of
standard disk or SSD and you can do
three terabytes of what we call attached
SSD which means in the previous is 64
terabytes ones those are just disks that
are associated with your machine does
not like physically attached the the
three terabytes of attached SSD are kind
of on the nose they are attached to the
hardware that you're working with which
means you can get much higher
performance and much higher I ops out of
them and I can go on and on about the
features and whatnot but I I feel like
one of the best ways to kind of look at
what our VMs can do is to actually
configure one so I'm going to do that
live run if you guys I'm gonna switch
over to the demo machine and let's build
a VM together so first thing I'm going
to do is we see all the list of all the
instances I have and I'm gonna create
one and let's see so we'll call this
delete me because I will eventually
delete it right let's see let's put it
in I can put it you know and any of our
data centers that we have around the
world but I will go with let's go with
la now I'll go with work it for
sentimental reasons will be clear later
let's see so I'll go I'll put it in a a
of my my options here now that's going
to determine what zone and what what
region I put it in are gonna determine
some of the capabilities of the machine
some zones don't have certain processor
types other zones have different
processor types or or GPUs available or
whatnot so I'll show that off in a
second so the next thing I want to do is
I'm gonna configure my machine type
you'll see we have a whole bunch of
pre-configured machine types up to 96
and the aforementioned down here at the
bottom 160 CPUs I'm just gonna do that
I'm gonna go 160 CPUs because I can't
and Google will pay for it that's a lot
now you know what I don't I don't want
my boss to have to approve that kind of
that's support so oh well actually one
of the things I can do here is instead
of just dialing in on these
pre-configured ones I can actually
customize and let's say I want to do I
don't know 26 processors I can it's
gonna change the memory profile of what
I can support but I can I can do that I
can extend the memory if I want to I can
choose to set a minimum CPU platform if
I want to and then you'll see here that
I do have GPUs available in this zone I
have a number of them I'm not going to
set them up but they are available let's
see all right so that's it for the
configuring machine I'm actually gonna
go back to a pre-configured one and then
let's see what else can I do here oh I
can change the boot disk right so you'll
see I have a number of options for OS
images I can start with I can go with
Ubuntu or core OS or SUSE or Red Hat's
or a number of a couple of Windows
flavors as well if that is the way you
like to roll I'm gonna just leave it to
default and I can also choose between
SSD and standard I'm going to leave it
standard just because I'm not gonna do a
lot of computing with this disk with
this machine I have this firewall
control because obviously one of them
most of the common things people do is
just open up HTTP or HTTPS but I can
actually do a little bit more then I'll
probably dig into that a little bit
let's see one of my options here
security I can set my own SSH keys great
I can encrypt my so all of our disks are
encrypted by default the only choice you
get here is whether or not you manage
the certs or we do customers can supply
their key that's important to crypt that
that's great networking you look a
little bit of the network settings every
VM gets two Network addresses one is the
private network and one is the public
one I can turn off the public one I
guess in furia can turn off the private
one I don't I don't I've never done that
because then I don't know how it would
communicate with things but
you in theory can you can give it a
static or ephemeral IP address you can
create one you can reserve one and you
can choose between our premium and our
standard networks premium network
basically uses our private backbone to
transmit all the data whenever a cut so
a customer goes and pull something from
one of your VMs it's gonna enter
Google's network as close to the
customer user as as possible because one
of our our pops our points of presence
around the world and then travel on our
network to to get to whatever VM that
you're going to if user standard we're
gonna operate more like another cloud
provider in which case we will let it go
over the public Internet as close to it
can before it has to go on our network
and so with the private network the
premium network you get a little bit
better a little bit more regular
performance and and it's on our network
the entire way so it's encrypted and
secure see what else do alright so
that's it oh one last thing I want to
show you here before I click create is
that so I configured a whole bunch of
things and down here at the bottom is
the equivalent rest or command line I
can actually click on this and get the
exact g-cloud command that I need to
create the machine that are configured
inside the in the interface here which
is awesome if you're building a whole
bunch of these you don't have to like
keep going to the console to do it and
conversely you don't have to sit and
kind of figure out all the options and
g-cloud you can just grab this run it
dump it into a script edit it and use it
repeatedly to build your machine I'm
gonna go ahead and build this and we
like to say or I like to say these will
spit up in tens of seconds meaning what
I'm in my hotel room practicing this
takes like 10 seconds when people are
watching it takes longer I don't know
how it knows it has performance anxiety
I guess when people are watching but in
a moment I should be able to see that
this is ready to go hopefully by the
time I get back here it'll be already
know you're watching
oh no there we go all right good
good there's a little SSH button here
which is one of my favorite features is
that all of these VMs you can just go
right through the browser will handle
pulling down those the SSH keys for you
and you don't have to if you don't want
to set up your own terminal to connect
to these machines so all this will
happen here and you'll see that we're
pulling down the certs and I'm all ready
to go and now I can I'm not gonna bump
it up a little bit but you know if I
want to have to get updates as debian I
don't remember that you need to be
subdued to do that so bang-bang there we
go and so there we are all ready to
start working with this machine start
pulling down software and you know I did
it right in front of you guys and you
know a couple seconds great okay so I am
going to switch back to my present
first thing is creating p.m. you can do
this all scripted via g-cloud all the
options are available all the
permutations are ready to go the next
step obviously would be running commands
and I was able to run command to the SSH
browser window but I can also do them
straight from my you know from remotely
as is using g-cloud compute SSH and then
the command also if I want to copy files
onto it I use g-cloud compute SCP source
and then destination and then I'll copy
files over so with those three commands
I can pretty much do a lot of migration
tasks right I can build a machine
install software on it and then push my
code to it and have it run and so all
three of those combined and that's
pretty much how you would approach
migration talk about some of our images
I'm gonna talk a little bit more about
disks in a moment but for images we have
multiple flavors of Linux and multiple
flavors of Windows you are free to use
any of those or bring some of your own
options and I'll talk about that a
moment but there they are there's some
of the options next thing is I talked
about IP addresses right we we said you
can a public or private you have static
or ephemeral we will give you static we
will give you ephemeral addresses
by default but if you decide not that
this ever happens right but you start
working with an IP address and realize
you should have had a static address and
you're afraid of losing it you can take
any ephemeral address that you get from
us and just flip it over to be static
for yourselves and it's important to
note that it only costs you if you don't
use the static IP address what that
means is using ephemeral doesn't cost
anything if you're using static and it's
attached to your machine it doesn't cost
you anything
if you use a static one and you pull it
off your machine and hold onto it which
you told there plenty of valid reasons
why you would do that it costs you when
it's not attached to a machine and
obviously the incentive here is that we
would prefer you not park a whole you
know ton of IP addresses and hastened
the IP for apocalypse that will happen
any day now as we're told
probably happened at the same time the
year of Linux desktop Athens so those
are IP addresses firewall I showed you
that you can open up HTTP or HTTPS the
firewall actually I'm gonna switch back
because it would be nice if I actually
showed the firewall controls so if we
switch back to the demo machine I'm just
gonna real quick set up a new firewall
rule on this machine so I'm gonna do
here is in the console I'm gonna go over
to BBC network firewall rules and we'll
create a new rule
let's go ahead and do that you'll see
that I give it a name let's call it
MySQL I was W lower case MySQL we can
turn on logs I'm just gonna leave it
ingress allow deny and we're gonna call
the target tag MySQL and we will specify
3306 great oh and I'm just gonna say
it's open to everyone because that's
great database administration there you
go and then I go back to my machines
instances delete me want to edit this
out of tag to it our tags as well
and there we go and just like that this
machine is now open on part pork 330 306
to whoever wants to get to it that's
pretty much how easy setting a firewall
role so firewall rules are for these
these instances so if we could switch
back to the prism thank you
let's firewall now let's get into some
not so basic stuff I think that's what
that's the getting started minimum that
you need to kind of get your machine up
and running but let's talk about some of
the things that make compute engine
maybe a little bit different so first
we'll start with our images right you
can start with ours which I listed a
whole bunch of them out but you could
always customize those images and then
save an image so you can start with our
version of Debian download all the
software you need on it get it all
installed and ready to go but maybe not
put your coat on just yet and then
create a static image of it and then use
that to build and boot your machines so
when you're building out fleets of
machines that's probably something you
need when you're using some of our other
tools like instance groups where you're
making multiple auto scaling machines
you at you at you actually have to do
this if you want if you want consistency
on all the boxes as they get built one
of the other things you can do is boot
from a container there's this little
switch up here this is deploy a
container image to the VM instance when
you click on that you get this whole
other set of options what you do is you
point this at a docker repo someplace
it could be Dockers one you pull down
just from straight docker or you can use
google container registry build your own
images post them there and then pull
them down there it'll basically just
launch compute engine with container OS
and docker running and shove your
container in and just start it up but
it's a kind of a quick easy way to just
get a container running pretty pretty
fast on our platform alright this one is
really cool so our compute engine VMs by
default do what we call live migration
which means that when we
you hardware or firmware updates on on
the machine the hardware that everything
is running on we don't take down your
VMs what we'll do is we'll copy the
entire memory space and the entire
basically everything that's going on all
the processes going on and move it over
to another instance seamlessly without
you being able to notice and what this
allows us to do is we do maintenance
you'll never see downtime for our
maintenance if there is hardware failure
of certain levels you won't see downtime
and then one of the big pluses of this
is for security updates there's a
there's a firmware level vulnerability
for Intel or I'm sorry I've been Intel
for a processor let's just we won't name
names a while back and a whole bunch of
her competitors we all had that
everybody across the industry had this
problem like we need to update the
harbor because this is a zero day
exploit that's really scary we were able
to do that without how causing any
downtime to the vast majority or
customers that had live migration
enabled other vendors had to have
rolling my rolling downtime in order to
handle this I'm actually gonna show a
demo of this in action because one of
the things that you can do is you can
force a live migration to happen so I'm
gonna switch over to back to demo and
we'll see here that I have a machine in
my list of instances called migrate okay
and that has an IP address so let's go
to the terminal here and I'm just going
to start picking it okay and then so
that's pinging and then in my other
window here see there we go
I'll make this a little bit bigger I
realize people see it there we go
you'll see there at the g-cloud command
to simulate a maintenance event
simulator maintenance event means tell
the VM that it's being it's having
hardware mania maintain maintenance and
it will do a live migration so I'm gonna
hit migrate here and at the same time
I'm gonna bump this up and you'll see
that we're getting really relatively
consistent ping times anywhere from 10
milliseconds to I've seen up to about
200 milliseconds some of this is
obviously dependent on the network that
I'm running on because it has to go from
this machine to Google but we are moving
this machine right now and you'll see
that there's almost no disruption now if
you have a more advanced surface if you
like because I'm just doing a pain right
that's not that taxing on the the
machine what we've seen is that you
won't drop connections but some
connections may take just a little bit
longer to answer while it's in the
process of migrating but we are still
migrating and we haven't seen any
downtime yet and we won't because we're
done and we've just moved a machine from
a different from one piece of hardware
to another without us seeing it surface
at all in the connectivity level what do
you guys think of that is that something
that you guys could use what's that
no oh okay all right tough room guys you
just had the look you know right alright
so I'm gonna switch back to my presence
of the options that I didn't touch here
is that you absolutely can attach GPUs
to your machines we have several types
of GPUs available mostly nvidia tesla ka
DSP 100 SP fours
t fours and the 100 to be use now it's
important I put this right after live
migration because these are things that
are specially attached to the hardware
that you're running and so basically you
can't do the live migration with them
running right if you are running GPUs
you cannot do a live migration
operation which kind of makes some sense
right because you know we have to have
the hardware the hardware is connected
we also have available something called
TP use which are Google's custom tensor
processing units that are optimized for
ML operations and that's a they are now
available for preemptable pricing and
I'll talk a little bit up craftable
pricing when I get to the pricing
section but basically if you have
advanced or users of ML work and you've
won a kind of turbocharged it switching
to TP use and activating that option in
your tensor flow or cloud ml II and or
cloud machine learning engine boxes will
make those operations faster and
ultimately cheaper right take a slight
detour and I want talk about something
called cloud shell so a lot of times
people set up VMs and set them up as a
workstation right they have one systems
workstation that they set up and use
that to connect to their entire cloud
infrastructure and you can do that we're
happy we're happy to have you do that
but we also have cloud show available
for you which is a browser-based
terminal CLI you saw the the the SSH
window that we kind of give you but we
also have it kind of hooked up to a
custom VM that is always available for
you
it has a home directory so you can store
commonly used scripts there and have
them migrate with you as you're you're
you're working on them but we don't
charge you anything for it so you can
just always have it available and I'm
gonna switch back and show it just how
to get to it and how to use it up here
at the top of my console there's this
little terminal looking thing I'm gonna
go ahead and activate cloud she'll see
it's gonna provision a machine for me
and I can always open this in a new
window and we'll see that or establish
our connection and what's great about
this is I don't have to maintain any of
the software on here I can use g-cloud
projects
projects list and so g-cloud is running
on this it's all up to date it's all the
latest version same thing with the
kubernetes controls same thing with most
of the kind of universally used on on
Google cloud tools they're all updated
already for you to use so I'm gonna
switch back and oh let's talk about
metadata so one of the cool things that
we have built into our platform is the
metadata platform so whenever you're
using one of our machines you have
access to this storage space it's a key
value storage space where you can find
out information about your VM you can
find information about your project or
you can even find you can even put and
take out custom metadata and I actually
do have a quick demo for this just
because it's kind of interesting so I'm
gonna switch back here and I'm gonna go
and I have some commands already written
out because they're long so let me go
ahead and copy and paste this and let's
go to let's go to the and we're gonna
log into the deleteme machine that I
made and we're gonna try and find some
stuff out so what's really helpful about
this if you're doing anything that you
need to pull the IP address of the
machine or you want to write code that
you don't have to hard code the any of
the names of the machines into but when
you're running grab the name and the
machine from or different things about
the project you can pull them from here
so what I'm gonna do is drop this in and
you'll see I had the enter there but
basically I just curled metadata google
internal compute metadata instance name
and I got I got word where to go it was
there a second ago
there we go delete me was the name in
the machine and I got to do that at the
project level right so I can go back
here and
let's grab this one so again a lot of
times I'm writing custom code and I
don't want to know I like I don't want
to hard-code any of the project details
into it I could just use this and get
this one important thing is that you
want to always make sure you include
that header down to the end of it that
metadata flavor google otherwise it'll
return an error but basically any of the
SDK for any of the language runtimes and
you might run on here
you usually have this built in so they
can just pull this information but you
can get to it directly and deal with it
however by just grabbing the the URLs
this is all secure
so for for machine metadata it's
actually doing a process under the
covers and know the request and the data
never leaves the the VM itself for
project I also believe that it's stored
it's grabbing data that's locally but I
I have not I'm not 100% certain of that
but just be aware that you can you can
there the you can trust that that data
is not being transmitted anywhere all
right I'm gonna switch back to present
so now let's talk about pricing and like
I said pricing is a giant hurdle I think
a lot of times with VM projects and
basically the logic goes something like
this it used to be the case where you
buy you over by Hardware right because
you're gonna amortize that over three or
five or eight years and so you've wanted
to be able to grow to your to your usage
three to five years from now
so you over by which is totally valid
strategy when you're doing on-prem stuff
because you're planning for growth but
then you do that same process and you go
oh I'll go to the cloud and I had you
know 1064 CPU boxes I'm just gonna
repeat that and do the same thing and
you get this bill that's sort of
outrageous and that combined with the
fact that you're not actually using all
of that processing power means that
you're you're not just overpaying you're
overpaying for stuff that you're not
using right so kind of we have a couple
things to encourage strategies for you
to kind of curb your usage
to kind of conform to the way that
you'll get the best pricing on on us wow
that was a it was a complex sentence I
just stood there all right so let's
start with the first one which is our
sustained use discount so one of the I I
kind of talked to that whole process
where you over by and your plan for
growth well we do that too right so we
take on a risk and buy extra machines in
the hopes that people will use them and
pay that pay us for that risk is still
there and that's still a risk for us so
anytime that we can push that risk on to
our customers we'll make a deal right
well will lower the price because it's
good for us to share some of this risk
so if you have long running machines
that's good for us because the longer
and more consistent you guys are running
machines the more easy we can plan for
growth right because it's more
consistent so we like regular usage we
like long running machines so the longer
you use the the machines the longer will
give you a discount so you get up to 30%
off of our list price over the course of
a month for running a VM now it's
important to note that this is
calculated over all of your instances
and not just one or two so for example
if you spin up a half you spit up a box
for half a month and then spin up
another box for half a month we'll
actually combine that into a full month
of a box even though they were separate
we call that inferred instances so let
me kind of show you how this looks from
a machine standpoint so day one end of
month I start with one machine and I run
it for half the month and then I need to
add additional capacity so I'm running
to a second machine also for part of the
month I had a third machine for the back
half of the month
and then I add some extras right so I'm
running five machines total none of them
are running for a full month so you
wouldn't necessarily expect to get the
full discount but what we do is we lump
these all together right so we cut off
five and split it into this and
basically we kind of go from the start
of when the machine ran the earliest and
then plan out for a whole month you'll
see that one in three combined to become
a full machine
two four and five combined to become a
majority of a machine and five is a
partial so then we calculate the
discount by saying okay this set of
machines that we are counting as one
gets 100 percent of the discount thirty
percent off the second one ran for about
80 percent of the month so we'll give it
80% of that discount and then the fifth
the fifth one ran for just around 25
percent of the month and so that's how
I'm calculate their sustained use not
just on each individual part as as it
relates to a month so more you run the
cheaper we are and we're happy we're
happy to have your consistent usage okay
so that's sustained use discount the
great thing about that is you don't have
to do anything like you I mean other if
you want to game it you can certainly
kind of for a make sure you're getting
the best one you want but if you just
run a VM we just apply this
automatically there's no switch you have
to flip or anything so the next pricing
control we have is something called
committed use discount and we fought
this for a long time because committed
use struck us is decidedly uncloudy
right you're taking a machine and saying
I will run this machine for three years
I'll run this machine for one year which
basically you just moved your hardware
commitment from your your data center to
us without really taking advantage of
the fact that well in the cloud if you
need more you can ask for more if you
need last you can ask for less so we do
it a little bit differently you're not
committing yourself to a machine
you're not saying I will have this 164
core box for the next three years you're
paying for a allotment of processors and
RAM and will give you up to 50% off
depending on your configuration or
whatnot but here's the thing you can
configure this however you want and you
can change it anytime so let's say I buy
300 I agree to buy 320 cores memory
would also apply it but would make the
math a lot uglier and I can't do math on
the fly so we'll just say for the sake
of argument this is just our processor
allocation memory is also involved with
we're not going to show so I have 320
cores I split it up into 16 20 core
boxes great further down the road I
figure out that like man I
need beefier machine to do this one set
of operations why can what I can do is
tear down the four of the twenties and
turn it into an eighty and this is still
the same thing so it's still the same
discount it's still the same everything
because it's the same number of
processors total and I can do it the
other way right I can go lower I can
break up some of my machines into
smaller I can do whatever as long as I
am still at the same processor
allocation the committed use discount
will apply and all of our agreements are
all in place
great now if you need more obviously you
can you can you can do committed use
along with other strategies you can just
buy an extra VM but once you commit to
this you will pay for these for the the
term of your term of your commitment
regardless so and there's another way
all right so that has been pricing
tricks and now I want to talk about some
of our usage controls so we have
something called custom vm's I showed
you you could dial in exactly the number
of processors in memory that you wanted
and what this allows you to do is a lot
of times you look at those those preset
configurations for machines right you've
got your your - your for your eight your
16 32 64 but like you may find that one
of your processes runs perfectly at 20
processors right like that's the optimal
so you're kind of left with a choice
right do you understand maybe not be as
performant as you possibly can be
or do over spec at 32 and just say well
I'll waste that money because you know
I'm not paying it right my bosses pay
but what you can do is dial in exactly
the 20 with us and get the exact
performance you need for as little money
as possible you can pay for it and
actually I have a demo of this some of
us switch back to the machine here and
I'm gonna start this off and then
explain what I'm doing because it does
take about two minutes to run so I have
here you'll see 64 I'm sorry 32 machines
ready to go and calling out to the api's
to request machines for them and you'll
see that's
two four six it's it's all the the
permutations of custom VMs I can use now
what's gonna happen is these boxes are
going to spin up and they're gonna
calculate a hundred million digits of pi
on each box as soon as they start up the
reason why I do that is because that is
a very processor intensive operation but
the tool that we use for crunching PI
kind of at some point you you you don't
get better performance by adding more
processors to it and so what's gonna
happen is all of these machines are
gonna spin up and we'll see which one
does it the fastest and we'll also see
which one does it the like optimal
performance for cost so the first part
of what we're doing here the was the
requesting from our data center so
basically say hey we would like a VM and
the data center takes a little bit of
time to figure out like do we have
capacity for this yeah we do or we don't
and but it looks like in most cases we
we didn't have capacity the next thing
it does is build right so we're gonna
take the processor and memory
configuration that you asked for find it
in the data center kind of lump them
together and then turn them into a
machine after we build we're gonna
configure the network to make sure that
it can talk publicly or and privately
and then after it does that it's
obviously going to boot its operating
system and then the first thing it does
after it's all done it's boot operations
and it immediately calculates a hundred
million digits of pi using Y cruncher so
we'll see this is happening we'll see I
wonder which one is gonna win I know
which one is optimal cuz I've done this
like hundreds of times but you know it's
always surprises me which one wins
there's no real difference in terms of
speed of boot process by how can how you
configure your machine it used to be
that that the custom numbers were a
little bit longer because we already pre
allocated some of them preset numbers
that doesn't seem to be the case anymore
and so let's see we already have a
winner the winner was
while the screen is so big I can't tell
I can't read it from here let's see so
40 processors one but we're still
checking along this is like I said this
usually takes about two minutes to
finish we're just gonna let it finish
out what it's done we're gonna do is
we're gonna isolate just the PI
calculation and look at the the curve it
creates we're done that one and that one
should be done any second so a lot of
interesting observations 41 but a lot of
the winning with a lot of the
high-performing ones were sort of down
here in the lower processor range so
let's isolate PI calculation and you'll
see that we get a nice curve right
there's definitely processor related but
eventually it kind of craps out and it
doesn't get any better just because you
had more processors to it having done
this hundreds of times it's around 28
processors is where it starts to become
kind of you're you're not getting
benefits out of adding more machines but
as we see 28 in terms of the total cost
of how much this cost we go from the
smallest thing we could do a to
processor box all the way up to 64
processor box and our price starts at
point 2 cents for that operation all the
way up to six and a half cents for the
operation so one we just calculated a
hundred million digits of pi on multiple
machines that we spun up from nothing
just right now which is kind of cool and
we were figured we were able to figure
out what the optimal processor was for
this or about about 28 so that's great
I'm gonna switch back to my presence and
BMS now I'll talk about preemptable VMS
which is another strategy we have via
printable VMS are one-fifth the cost of
our normal VMs so just on just outright
at the door just one-fifth the cost
however they will disappear in 24 hours
sometime in the next 24 hours they'll go
away it could be any time in that 24
hours but they'll definitely go away
within 24 hours you'll lose the machine
you get about 30 second warning
it just kind of goes away but then what
you can do is like you could always
request another one and we'll give it to
you so what is this for it's not for
running your permanent you know
ecommerce or website presence it's not
it's not for anything that's user facing
it's for bash work it's for work that
you don't you don't care when it gets
done right it can it can it can support
having an interruption and restarting so
queue processing batch work anything
like that so let's kind of show how this
would work so I have machine here this
is the this is the micro we're gonna
bump it to the one CPU we're gonna bump
it to 32 and then we're gonna pump it
all the way up to 96 and when we get
there we've seen the price per month is
$2,300
I was calculated that's $3,300 for the
actual full cost of it and then you're
getting $1,000 off in the sustained use
discount if you're running it for the
full month and that's how we arrive at
2300 with preemptable VM what you get is
we the total cost drops and started the
original cost drops to 701 because it's
one fit of that 3500 but you don't get
the sustained use discount and then it
comes out at 701 dollars so this is a
really great strategy for lowering a
cost for operations that don't need to
happen at a particular time particular
moment the let I'm sorry is there a
question yes that's a great question so
one you can always just do it manually
right you have to check to see if it's
up and right right but we don't want to
do that the way most of our customers
who are using this as a strategy do it
they and I'm gonna talk about this in a
right now instance groups where you can
create these groups that you say have a
minimum a maximum have them always
running you can set them to be
preemptable so if one of those machines
goes down it'll start back up and that's
probably the best strategy for doing it
yes
No
so they they will live at some time they
will live for up to 24 hours so that is
the longest they'll live but they can in
theory shut down immediately after you
start them up because the what's
happening under the covers is we have
machines that aren't being used
allocated in certain ways and certain
data centers and whatnot when you ask
for one of these preemptively and you're
saying I want it but I don't want it
that badly right so what will happen is
is within that 24 hours if someone
another customer comes along and says no
no I need I need this machine all the
time and I'm gonna pay the full price
for it we say well that's the deal we
made and we'll we'll take it so that's
why you don't have any control over how
long it was like maybe no one asks for
it you get it the whole 24 hours maybe
maybe someone asks for it immediately
and you're it's taken away all right I'm
gonna try to get to this next section
and I'll leave time for questions at the
end so as I'm saying before one of the
things once you want to start scaling
out once you want to start making your
operations bigger or a little bit more
self managing what you're gonna want to
do is take the next step towards managed
and unmanaged instance groups these are
groups of machines that are all
connected to a well there are groups of
machines that's really all they are the
covers they're not that useful unless
you hook them up to a load balancer in
which case then you can have them share
responsibilities but if you have a
managed or unmanaged group manage groups
you have to create an image template so
you'll create a disk like I outlined
before you'll create a machine profile
and you will say this is the template
for this and create create machines in
this group - this template then because
they're all exactly the same we can do
things like auto scale and auto heal
them we can say all we could say like
have the processor utilization always be
60% and so if it goes above 60% we will
spit up more instances for you if it
drops below 60% over all your instances
will spin down one to you for you with
you being able to set min and Max so you
may wanted to say
like min three all the time right just
so I have some redundancy and also some
redundancy and then set an upper limit
like this should never go to 20 machines
so if it does there's a problem so how
the max be 20 unmanaged groups are again
a collection of machines you hook up to
a load balancer the only difference here
is that they're heterogeneous and
because they're heterogeneous we really
can't do we can't do no auto nothing
right like we can't we don't know the
impact of adding another machine because
you have all different sets of
processors allocations that's fine so
you can set these up this way and then
finally you're gonna want to hook one of
these up to our load balancers and we
have a couple different flavors a load
balancer rhtp HBS load balancer which is
sort of the equivalent of what other
people who would you refer to as an l7
load balancer TCP and UDP are network
load balancers it's are running at l4
and then all of these either of these
you can set up to be internal only so
that it's only routing internal traffic
now I'm gonna walk through the console
of these things real quickly but I'm not
gonna set anything up because it usually
takes a little bit of time so I'm gonna
switch to the the demo monitor here oh
yeah perfect
and let's look at this so let's see here
we're gonna start with our instance
groups now I have an instance group
already set up you'll see that I have
three instances running and I have a
rule that the target CPU utilization is
always 60 we can go in and we can see
this is a managed group so that it's it
will auto scale and all this I have a
template set up for it I'm just gonna go
through and want to mess around with the
minimums here I'm gonna say minimum five
instead of three and then I'm gonna set
the maximum to ten and I'll save that
and all of this is wired up to a load
balancer so let me go here and we'll see
their load balancer and this is pretty
basically says straightforward I get a
front end which is my IP address in
which case this is an HP load balancer
so it's it's doing mostly HTTP and I can
set up host host pads and rules or I can
just have it just just
completely auto-load balance the whole
the whole thing but I could set up
multiple backends to work on different
paths on the front end here so I can I
have a lot of control over that and then
down here I have my back-end services
which was that instance group I just
showed you earlier and so if I go to
this IP address you'll see my really
exciting default Apache web page because
I was really kind of throwing this
together quickly there we go so that's
running so that's one of those boxes is
responding and then finally in that last
step I at some point updated the number
of machines and will see that it is
currently spinning up those machines
they're basically it's the process of
creating them right now so that's why
they're kind of labeled red but because
I said minimum five instead of minimum
three that's why it's spinning out more
all right I'm looking at my time and I'm
looking at my presence oh I'm going to
switch back to the presentation and
let's see so a couple quick conclusions
one there are other products in DCP that
use compute engine as the underpinnings
for the for the for the product for
example kubernetes engine is using
straight compute engine VMs under the
covers and same thing with data flow
data proc and cloud shell why is this
relevant why is this important because
you can use some of the strategies you
would use maintaining compute engine
instances with these products for
example
kubernetes engine is for managing
containers you're running host nodes
that run kubernetes on it you can do
things like create a managed instance
group that is made up of entirely
preemptable VMs and have that support or
container work so you can dramatically
lower the cost of running a kubernetes
engine cluster by moving some of the
work onto preemptable VMs because you
can set it up with all through compute
engine same kind of strategies apply for
dataflow and data prop and cloud shell
has access to the metadata too so all of
these things add up you may want to look
at applying some of the stuff that we
talked about here to one of these also
these other products
also you get a free tier of compute
engine just by having a project so your
first f1 micro instance is free in
perpetuity
so it's not a very beefy box it's a
shared processor with six gigs of RAM
but if you just want to play around and
start fooling around with VMs if you
haven't already you can use that and
kind of dip your feet in with that I
will say this was for me a new talk so
please feel free to give me feedback
obviously if you liked it great but if
you have constructive feedback I would
definitely love to hear it
so do that through the through the next
app all right thank you everybody and
like I said I'll be around I do have
questions thank you
[Applause]
[Music]